you are back in the blue but apparently
they've simplified the bluing of you
yeah turns out they never had to do
eight hours of full-blown body pain ever
so do they is it CGI now or something or
no I wish um then I'd be like maybe take
a little off the thigh no it's like a
blue like pantyhose that goes around my
whole body that I can't sit to pee in I
can't do any form of bathroom like the
guy who made it we're like when she's a
girl she didn't go to the bathroom so
standing up out of a funnel yeah I've
actually buckston Tokra I'm burst into
her bathroom with a BB gun while she was
trying to pee so hard to do because stop
while you're in the middle of peeing to
let the rest of it go out like that's a
whole scientific I'm trying really hard
I'm like there's a lot going on and then
he burst in and started pelting me and
it wasn't fair because we were all
shooting each other with guns but you
all were all in clothes we were all
going naked we were telling this
Saturday and we were saying like she's
everywhere and she's like huddled on the
floor in her bathroom naked and me naked
Michael me and my naked I'm we're done
loading on her
you
I walk over at this point I write oh god
maybe he won't remember it will be
humiliated as well you don't want to be
dog shop because he's the way he speaks
is very specific yeah were you telling
all the Mexicans to get upset